[Musique]
je vais y aller donc non mais c'est pas
une question c'est qui c'est du let
je ne peux pas car dans la poche et ne
la connais pas du tout ma gueule je sais
pas tout une philippe balasse et
carbonisés mariage tu apprennes paraître
son mariage avec tableau fait ta
maîtresse était mon héros toi c'est
alexis labro faire de mort elle est
toutefois mal à l'aise où tu dis n'est
pas nouveau ceo a alors ces châteaux
bénéficie d'une magnifique terrasse pour
la réception de mariage ce sera super
vient pas donc le château de l'église du
sens à ce pas
regarde là bas j'adore mais il ya trop d
espace comment on va la fin 2010
alors vous verrez baiser maître qui
parle de toi de nous ah oui jeudi
j'étais un peu stressé je suis dit mais
qui sont compris film alors pour se
rassurer juste avant de se marier ils
sont prêts à sauter sur la première fois
ce contenu
tu vois oui
mais qu'il devrait choisir entre les
deux
je prends des deux
tant qu'un dealer je peux pas dû faire
ça adapter une vie super
m
[Applaudissements]
faut pas que fut malheureux c'est parce
que tu es tranquille pas inquiète pas je
chante pas qui coûte à militer avec les
tiens ah ouais ok d'accord et fraîche
s'occupa